okay another trick question you mean how
many has he played or how many has he
actually qualified for how many has he
qualified for okay wow um let's see so
wow
okay you ready for some Magnus Carls and
trivia I'll do pretty badly but sure
let's do okay let's do it what is Magnus
Carlson's birthday his birthday is
November I believe November 30th it's is
20th or 30th I think it's the 30th it's
November 30th yeah you know the year
well I'm 87 and he's part yeah he's part
of that next Generation so it should be
1990 nailed it where was Magnus Carl's
important now this one is tricky because
I I get these cities confused uh it's
with a t but the problem is in my mind I
always want to say it's Tron high but
that's not the right one it's a it's
um it's uh is it it's
uh it's tburg right it's tburg that's
what it is there's a lot of T tromo but
you got a tburg but I always confus that
Tron and actually there's a picture of
like the hospital room on the Wikipedia
page and I thought it was kind of
strange there is it's like there's a
picture of like the window or the
hospital itself and I just thought it
was kind of weird that they memorialized
that but anyway whatever beside the
point all right at what age did Magnus
Carlson become a
grandmas that should
be it's getting younger that should be
it's 13 or 14 I'm pretty sure it was at
13 years old I don't I don't remember
exactly how many days correct 13 years
days how many siblings does Magnus have
okay so um okay so there he has he has
at least three sisters I know that for
sure I'm trying to think if it's more
than that is it three or is it four I'm
going to assume
there I think it's four sisters so I
think that I think it's uh it's three
it's oh it's three I'm wrong yeah but
can you name them can you name the three
of them uh definitely I mean I know
there's Ellen um there's one with s i
and there's one other one but no I can't
name okay what happened first Magnus
winning the Norwegian Chess Championship
or you winning the US Chess Championship
so I won the US Championship in
2000 this could be a trick question
though because when I won the US
championship in 2005 it was not held in
2005 it was held in 2004 so this could
be a trick question um but I'm going to
assume Magus 1990 so he would have been
14 I'm I'm going to assume that I I won
the US championship before he won the
Norwegian Championship but I could be
wrong on that correct you did what is
magnus's favorite opening move in over
theboard games I'm going to assume it's
E4 but I honestly don't know correct
he's played E4 762 times and D4 555
times okay on chess.com
specifically under his Magnus Carlson
account what is magnus's favorite
opening move for online what's his
favorite move uh it's probably not E4
I'm going to guess that it's um let me
think about this
I'm going to guess it is Knight F3 it's
E4 it is E4 okay who did Magnus play in
his first fed World Championship oh this
I remember very well th this was
actually cuz magnus's rise was very
quick and I I remember this very well he
played I think he played the World Cup
and then he played Iceland those were
two very very critical moments for him
in the World Cup I remember was very
well he played leavon aronian in 2004
and in trip and I remember this also
because um like I was playing the first
round too against a Russian player I won
in won in like the first two tiebreak
games but magnus's match against leavon
went very deep I think went to like six
games I think in the tie break if I'm
not mistaken um and everyone was
watching that match very closely because
leavon was considered one of the big
favors to win the World Cup so it was
against leavon Aron tripy that was great
we thought we were going to get you with
that trick question but I remember that
very well you nailed it okay what do you
have geny bereev gakamsky buhang XI and
Yan shist off Duda all have in common oh
they've they've all um I'm I think it's
pretty obvious they've all beaten Magnus
in the World Cup nailed it okay how many
candidates Tournaments has Magnus
Carlson qualified
for okay another trick question you mean
how many has he played or how many has
he actually qualified for how many has
he qualified for okay wow um let's see
so wow okay I'm going to assume that
this is before he became world champion
so I'm going to assume he qualified in
2008 the world championship was in I
always get the years confused here the
candidates was in 2013 I believe in
London if I'm not mistaken so it would
have been he would have qualified 2007
was the World Cup he didn't that was the
one that csky I think won if I'm not
mistaken so it would have been 9 11 13
so I'm going to guess it's it's three
it's my guess
four 2007 2011
2013 and then eventually 2024 oh so
you're counting this I wasn't sure if
you're counting this one but that's the
part of the trick question right all
right let's see how many tries did it
take for Magnus to win the main event
not the blitz of Norway chess Norway
chess okay so if I really want to do
this mathematically I can probably
figure it out but it he the first year I
believe was 2013 he didn't win
145 um was it 15 or was it 16 that he
won trying to remember soz I did play I
feel like he didn't I feel like the
first time he won was actually a year
that I was not there for some reason so
I'm going to guess that it he played 13
14 15 I'm going to guess that it was the
fourth try of was 2016 very good wow I
was right yeah took his fourth try okay
who did Magnus Carlson beat to claim the
highest peak rating of all time to beat
so okay so this was the London chess
classic actually this is um more
complicated because I remember this very
well also cuz I played Magnus in round
eight I believe I think it was nine
round event London chess classic and
when I was not able to beat Magnus in
the white pieces in this in an alen
Sicilian that ensured that Magnus would
be be published with a higher rating
than Gary Kasparov so it was definitely
in London um so I assume you're talking
live ratings who did he beat there to to
guarantee it um London chest classic um
this was 2012 2013 yeah I I don't know
I'm not going to I'm not going to spend
all day thinking about it the answer
they have is he beat hikaro Nakamura on
April 21st at the 2014 shum Kier event
and that gave him a
2889 you're asking a different question
who did he beat that gave him the
highest his highest rating of oh yeah
yeah okay okay actually but that I
believe if you're asking about sham K
that's when he set the highest rating
was it is win against me or is win
against Fabiano in the last round I
don't know probably in the live ratings
it was win against me but he also won a
very big game I think in the last round
against Fabiano which which uh which I
think helped a lot also first rating
good what happened first you playing a
classical game versus Magnus or him
winning the Norwegian Championship so
that that game and Bill would have been
July of 2005 so I'm going to I'm going
to assume that probably my game against
Magnus happened first correct okay
Magnus recently co-authored a chess book
who did he co-author it with and what is
the title I don't know the title but
it's it's a book with um it's a book
with like David Howell MH grind like a
Grandmaster grind like a Grandmaster
okay one of magnus's first sponsors was
a clothing company what was that company
those are the very early days I remember
t.com was at that event in New York City
um but yeah the company would be gar raw
nice which of these has Magnus Carlson
won five of classical World Champs Blitz
World Champs rapid World Champs uh
classical nailed it what is the name of
Magnus Carlson's twitch Channel and do
you know how to pronounce it I mean the
the name is well I mean I I know what
how you spell it I probably Mis
pronounce but I think it's masinis
correct will we see more from the ma
maskinen uh t which in the future I have
to say that your um pronunciation is
abysmal mosan mosan how how I yeah who
did Magnus Carlson beat with 1 F3 at the
2022 Champions chess tour Champions
chest tour ah I thought you were going
to ask about a different game where he
was F3 I think that would have been uh I
think that was we if I'm not mistaken it
was Duda oh was dudah oh was we H4 we
might have been H4 okay it was dudah
okay PA F3 what a strange opening which
TV show did Magnus Carlson appear in in
2017 in
2017 um I believe that would be the
Simpsons nice in addition to chess
Magnus Carlson has been ranked the
number one player in the world at one
other thing what is that thing that's
Fant fantasy football European football
to be clear nice Fantasy Premier League
nailed it during the classic match
Carlson fresen a 2013 what was Magnus
Carlson's famous
quote oh oh this was this was at the
training camp this wasn't an actual
match um it was uh uh two I believe it
was two week too slow nailed it two
weeks just
go all right Magnus Carlson trivia
w